in the first stock will be given by Zee
Scully who will tell us about the
robustness of the gitens index
so thanks Lanka so hi everyone I'm Steve
I just graduated from CMU I'm going on a
bit of a journey and I'll end up at
Cornell starting as an assistant
professor in Ori uh starting next fall
and I'm very excited about that so and
what I want to talk about today is a
theme that I explored in my thesis in
the kind of context of scheduling and
queuing systems but that I'm very
interested in exploring more broadly and
that's part of why I'm really glad to be
here this semester uh with lots of
experts in kind of different areas to
see to what extent these ideas have
likes beyond the queuing world
um and this idea is something called the
gettings index so I'll say I'm actually
barely going to talk about what the
gayson's index is but what the main
thing you need to know for this talk is
that the gations index is a sort of uh
General technique for solving a variety
of stochastic optimization problems that
involve choosing between lots of
independent Alternatives so you can
think of a multi-arm Band-Aid problem
and specifically the gesians index
solves the Bayesian multi-around problem
um it also solves Pandora's Box problems
um and uh one I'll talk about today
which is scheduling in queues
um and but the common sort of thing
about the guesses into in all of these
settings is that there are optimality
proofs but these proofs are brittle if
you slightly perturb the assumptions all
of a sudden you don't have optimality
anymore it becomes much less clear what
we should do so for example all of these
optimality proofs rely on having a
single server that is you're pulling one
arm at a time opening one box at a time
serving one job at a time what should we
do if we have multiple servers
um also all of these optimality proofs
kind of assume that you've implemented
gettings perfectly with exact
computations uh it turns out the gates
index it's actually a number that is
sort of how good is this arm how good is
this job to serve what if you don't
exactly compute that number because it
could be hard to compute the optimality
proofs don't uh give us a good idea and
then the last thing is that all of these
settings are cases that I'll call like
they have a fully specified stochastic
model one way to say say this is that
you can formalize this as an mdp where
you know all of the parameters typically
just solving that mdp is kind of too
expensive which is why we care about
things like the Gibson index which gives
us a sort of neater solutions to
optimality but what if we don't have
full knowledge of all the parameters
okay so and the way I sort of view all
of these questions is they all are
instances of or at least kind of related
to versions of this question which is do
near Jason's policies have near Optimal
Performance so as an example I think of
multiple multi-server uh scheduling or
multi-server multi-unbounded as well if
I'm pulling the two best arms uh that's
kind of like pulling the best arm you
know twice as hard roughly speaking so
that's kind of nearly up to nearly
getting Z so is that nearly optimal and
uh in my thesis I studied this question
in the context of scheduling in queues
and so that's what I'm going to focus on
today so let me tell you a bit about
what scheduling in the queues even looks
like so this is a single server queue uh
we have a server that can serve jobs
that are arriving over time jobs that
are waiting for service will be in this
queue and this is a job so a job is
going to be a test tube its height is
its size that's how long it needs to be
served for and we'll represent that
service as filling the test tube with
water and so we can talk about the
progress we've made so far in a job it's
age and then the remaining work called
its remaining size
and we have these jobs arriving over
time According to some stochastic
process and the important thing about
the stochastic process that you need to
know today is that each job's size is
independently drawn from some
distribution s
okay
um so at some point we'll finish a job
when this job exits the total amount of
time it's been around from arrival to
completion is called that job's response
time this is sort of both the time
serving the job and sort of time is
spent waiting and so we want low
response times right because we don't
like waiting most of us
um so that's the sort of main metric
we're going to care about today okay and
now we have a choice right we have an
empty server we get to choose which job
to serve next and so once when I say
scheduling what I'm really talking about
is continuously making this decision
what job am I working on and I can
decide to change my mind at any point
and start working on a different job
okay so
um if I don't like response time right I
want low waiting I might ask how should
I schedule in order to minimize the
average response time over all jobs
so this is a classic question and in
this setting where I sort of can see
each job's size age remaining size I
have perfect information the classically
known answer is something called
shortest remaining processing time I
always serve whichever job has the least
remaining size the intuition is that
whatever I can get off my plate the
quickest I should work on that and
that's sort of reducing the sort of
average number of jobs that are always
waiting and that's kind of a helpful
thing
okay so this is the sort of known size
scheduling what about scheduling with
unknown sizes okay so what does this
look like so it looks like I have a test
tube but I don't know how tall the test
tube is I'm just going to fill it with
water and at some point the test tube
will politely inform me that it's done
and exit the system
okay so how should I schedule in this
sort of world so first what what are we
even using when making our scheduling
decisions in this world well one thing
we can see on the slide is that I've
drawn the Aging right it's reasonable to
assume we know each job's age because we
can measure how long we've spent serving
the job so far it's also pretty
reasonable to assume that oh we can know
the job size distribution say from
historical data although I'll return to
this at the end of The Talk
and So based on these two things an idea
we might say is well I don't know a
job's remaining size but it could
compute its expected remaining size
and so this would result in a policy
called s-e-r-p-t always serve the job at
least expected remaining size
and so
um the way I like to sort of write down
what this policy looks like is that it
assigns each job a rank or priority as a
function of how long I've been serving
it and so uh and we'll use the
convention that lower rank is better and
so a jobs rank is going to be its
expected remaining size conditional on
having reached age a so that's this is
the remaining size this is conditioning
on the fact that the job is has reached
AJ and thus isn't smaller than it right
and so just as an example if for this
particular job size distribution this is
what scrpt looks like it's kind of
adapting its priorities based on
information it's learning as a job
passes age one we realize oh shoot this
job isn't just size one it's going to be
bigger so I'll give it a worse rank
similar deal at age six
and so serps is this kind of very nice
idea right natural generalization of
srpt
turns out it's not optimal which uh you
would guess if you remember the second
slide of the talk where I told you that
there's this thing called the gisens
index and that this gives the optimal
solution so the Gibson's index it's a
bit more complicated than serp but has a
very similar intuition behind it with
some fancier details you can ask me
about so it's more complicated but it's
optimal
okay and this is a sort of classically
known result
um although uh even talk to me after if
you're curious about exactly what
classically known this means because it
turns out it was a bit more complicated
okay so this is basically this is kind
of what Jason's index looks like in
single in single server schedule I'm
taking the job size distribution my
stochastic model and I'm kind of
crafting on a job by job basis this
priority function based on that job size
distribution and this and basically by
just always serving the job of least
rank
I end up with this optimal scheduling
policy
when I have a single server and when I'm
exactly Computing this whole thing uh to
exact precision and when I exactly know
the job size distribution s
okay so so this optimality results
um right has that thing needs a single
server needs exact computations needs
fully specified stochastic mode
um and so in my thesis I study this
question and got two out of three so uh
so basically we showed that for some
definition of near optimal uh which is
actually different in each of these
bullets uh we showed that if you kind of
do the sort of natural generalization of
Visions in a multi-server setting where
you're basically instead of taking the
single best rank you take the K best
ranks and put those in your servers then
you get near optimal mean response time
if you only compute your distance
indices the gations ranks within some
multiplicative approximation ratio we
showed that you then end up with the
same approximation ratio uh in a sort of
near optimality result
um and the way we did this
um kind of and the thing the reason I'm
excited to explore this theme more is
less about you know these results but
more about the tools that underlie them
um and so my thesis is called a new
toolbox for scheduling Theory and two of
the tools in that toolbox you saw on the
title slide one is called wine the work
integral number equality
um and then another is a sort of General
way of thinking about queuing that's
called The Mark of process jump model
and these are and the both of these
ideas are things I think uh might have
analogs outside of queuing
um so I'd be happy to discuss them and
then the last theme that I think is
really important is uh thinking about
this fully specified area and there's
lots of open questions here so one
example would be I said it's reasonable
to assume we know the job size
distribution what if we've learned the
job size distribution from data we don't
know the exact distribution
how can we adapt cases for that setting
do we need a distributionally robust
version of gits what does that even look
like
um I Know It uh I I have started
thinking about this problem but it's
very hard and I'm very interested to
collaborate with folks on these sorts of
things anyway thanks for your attention
happy to take questions
[Applause]
thanks for the lovely talk questions was
Eve and maybe the next speaker can set
up meanwhile as well
how do we know that it's nearer
uh can you repeat the question yeah sure
so the question is uh what do we even
know about the optimal solution in the
multi-server setting the answer is we
don't know very much what we actually
show is that uh gations with multiple
servers in certain uh under some
generous some generous assumptions it
actually approaches something even
better than the optimal multi-server
policy it approaches single server cases
if you smush all the servers together
into one big bad server which is even
better than having a multi-server system
um
and actually exact lower bounds on the
multi-server optimal are still an open
question in QA
maybe time for another question does any
no thanks again and go to the next talk
[Music]
yeah so the next stop is an incentive
aware machine learning for decision
making by Chada